[Applauso]
Scommetto che molti di voi sono convinti
che il cambiamento climatico sia un
processo lungo
iniziato con la rivoluzione industriale
a cui noi Dobbiamo porre riparo per
evitare conseguenze sui nostri figli sui
nostri nipoti sulle prossime generazioni
quindi un processo lento una questione
di secoli
Purtroppo non è così
gli effetti di questo processo di scala
globale che riguarda tutti noi
indistintamente si vedono già oggi
Infatti siccità
intendi molto estesi Purtroppo molti di
noi ricorderanno queste immagini
alluvioni sono più che raddoppiati negli
ultimi 30 anni
Questa è Catania la mia città solo
qualche settimana fa
a causa di Apollo uno degli uragani del
Mediterraneo che non sono provocati dal
cambiamento climatico e la loro
intensità la loro aggressività che
aumentata a causa del cambiamento
climatico e quindi il loro impatto sulle
nostre città e sui nostri paesi
Ma cosa è dovuto il cambiamento
climatico
è dovuto alle emissioni di anidride
carbonica e altri gas serra
prodotti dalle attività umane
e guardiamo questo grafico
oltre metà delle emissioni di anidride
carbonica
dell'intera storia dell'umanità sono
state prodotte negli ultimi 35 anni
io ho 39 anni Questo significa che la
mia generazione ha provocato più
emissioni di quante ce ne siano mai
state nel corso dei secoli
Tuttavia una buona notizia c'è è
possibile combattere il cambiamento
climatico è possibile ridurre le
emissioni di anidride carbonica e gli
altri gas serra Ma come
il 73% delle emissioni è legato al
fabbisogno che l'uomo ha di energia e al
tipo di energia che utilizza per
soddisfare questo fabbisogno
possiamo quindi andare al lavoro con una
macchina a combustione per olio o diesel
con emissioni di anidride carbonica
oppure scegliere di utilizzare una
macchina elettrica che magari possiamo
caricare con l'energia elettrica
prodotta con Fonte solare senza
emissioni di anidride carbonica
Oppure possiamo riscaldare le nostre
abitazioni con caldaie a gas
oppure con pompe di calore ad alta
efficienza alimentare da nergy elettrica
prodotta da Fonte eolica ad esempio
Ebbene sai per soddisfare il nostro
fabbisogno di energia
utilizziamo l'energia elettrica che è
l'unica forma di energia che si può
produrre senza emissioni
possiamo contribuire a combattere il
cambiamento climatico
il processo in cui sostituiamo una forma
di energia come l'hai sempre il gas con
energia elettrica si chiama
elettrificazione è fondamentale
elettrificare quanto più possibile gli
usi finali dell'energia
così facendo sarà possibile cucinare
riscaldare trasportare produrre beni e
servizi semplicemente utilizzando
l'energia del vento l'energia del sole
energia idroelettrica
Purtroppo però non tutti gli usi finali
dell'energia possono essere
elettrificati
esistono alcuni settori in cui a causa
di ragioni tecniche o per costi elevati
di conversione non è possibile
sostituire il combustibile utilizzato
con l'energia elettrica Questi sono i
settori del trasporto marittimo a lunga
percorrenza il settore dell'aviazione
difficilmente potremmo attaccare un cavo
un aereo magari oppure mettere le
batterie particolarmente
energia elettrica sufficiente a tutto il
percorso oppure anche nell'industria
pesante in cui serve e tanta energia
concentrata quindi la produzione del
cemento la produzione di vetro la
produzione di acciaio Quindi come si fa
a ridurre le emissioni in questi settori
anche per questi settori
una tecnologia pulita esiste
ma bisogna chiudere col passato e
guardare verso il futuro
in questi settori di idrogeno può essere
una soluzione ma solo se si tratta di
idrogeno verde
sull'idrogeno però facciamo un passetto
indietro cerchiamo di capire qualcosa in
più
l'idrogeno è l'elemento più leggero e
più abbondante nell'universo
l'idrogeno è il combustibile
di cui si alimentano le reazioni di
fusione nucleare che avvengono le nostre
stelle E da questo straordinario
elemento che si origina l'energia
rinnovabile che ogni giorno la terra
riceve dal sole
terra ricca di ossigeno
idrogeno brucia producendo calore come
il metano ma differenza di altri
combustibili ha una densità
di energia per unità di peso molto alta
3 volte che l'hai la benzina
però Alessia di energia per unità di
volume e bassa quindi occupa tanto
spazio abbiamo comprimerlo
ma la differenza rispetto agli altri
combustibili principale e che bruciando
non emette anidride carbonica ma solo
acqua pura
Si notano sulla terra è anche presente
in abbondanza ma non lo troviamo mai da
solo lo troviamo sempre legato ad altri
elementi ad esempio troviamo nell'acqua
legato all'ossigeno
Oppure lo troviamo nel metano legato al
carbonio o nel carbone nel petrolio
quindi per produrlo dobbiamo separarlo
dagli elementi a cui è legato fornendo
energia
esistono tanti metodi di produzione
dell'idrogeno
tutti restituiscono la stessa molecola
ma con costi e impatti sull'ambiente
molto diversi
Ad ogni modo di produzione viene
associato un colore Quindi abbiamo
l'idrogeno marrone che è quello prodotta
a partire dal carbone
in questo caso per ogni kg di idrogeno
prodotto si mettono più di 20 kg di
anidride carbonica
che è la rete del Monica prodotta ad
esempio da un auto che si sposta da
Bologna a Firenze
poi abbiamo il dinosauro grigio idrogeno
prodotta a partire dal metano attraverso
il processo di Steam methane reforming
in questo caso per ogni kg di idrogeno
prodotto si mettono più di 9 kg di
anidride carbonica
e poi possiamo produrre idrogeno
attraverso il processo di elettrolisi
partendo dall'acqua e fornendo energia
elettrica possiamo separare l'idrogeno
dall'ossigeno
se l'energia elettrica che utilizziamo
energia elettrica rinnovabile
Stiamo producendo di Rozzano verde senza
alcuna emissione di anidride carbonica
questo è l'idrogeno che possiamo
utilizzare per decarbonizzare i settori
heartache quelli che non si possono
verificare che citavo prima
oggi sulla terra si produce già idrogeno
in grosse quantità
75 milioni di tonnellate l'anno perché
viene utilizzato in alcuni processi come
materia prima è sempre nella
raffinazione o nella produzione di
ammoniaca ma è tutto idrogeno marrone o
grigio con impatti sull'ambiente e non
enormi
pari alle emissioni del Regno Unito e
dell'Indonesia insieme ogni anno
E perché non si produce idrogeno verde
perché produrre idrogeno verde più
costoso
elettrolizzatori che sono una tecnologia
nota già da qualche secolo ancora non
sono prodotti su larga scala quindi
costano tanto
storia il mondo scientifico e
tecnologico e da tempo impegnato nel
ridurre i costi di produzione di
idrogeno verde e il traguardo sembra
ormai alle porte
devi accadere per gli elettrolizzatori
quanto accaduto già in passato per altre
tecnologie rinnovabili ad esempio il
costo dei pannelli fotovoltaici si è
ridotto di 9 volte in 10 anni
affinché ciò avvenga anche per gli
elettrolizzatori è necessario che la
politica
indirizzi correttamente i fondi dedicati
alla transizione energetica
puntando Oltre che su elettrificazione
efficientamento energetico e fonti
rinnovabili anche sul idrogeno verde
lasciandosi alle spalle
i combustibili fossili e tutte quelle
tecnologie che ne comportino
l'estrazione è l'utilizzo
ma è anche necessario che ognuno di noi
non importa Che mestiere faccia
contribuisca come può a combattere il
cambiamento climatico
scegliendo opportunamente prodotti e
servizi che non utilizzano combustibili
fossili
cominciamo Inizialmente è un processo di
scala globale e nessun individuo nessuna
nazione può combatterlo efficacemente da
solo È proprio per il fatto che processo
di scala globale e anche molto ingiusto
i paesi che potrebbero pagare per primi
le conseguenze del cambiamento climatico
sono i paesi più poveri
quelli per cui a causa della povertà
sarà più difficile se non improbabile
adattarsi alle conseguenze del
cambiamento climatico
e questi sono anche i paesi che hanno
contribuito meno
riscaldamento globale ha messo meno
anidride carbonica e hanno avuto meno
vantaggi ai processi che hanno provocato
il cambiamento climatico
l'Africa d'esempio è responsabile solo
del
3,6% delle emissioni di anidride
carbonica danno
ma sta già pagando il prezzo più caro
è nostro dovere Dunque unire giustizia
ed ecologia ed agire in fretta ed in
modo irresponsabile
anche nei confronti di queste
popolazioni
dobbiamo agire ora e scrivere il futuro
del nostro pianeta
evitando l'estinzione della nostra
specie
[Applauso]